as you may have guessed i'm writing a
story here just kind of retelling the
story of priscilla
whose idea to
drag this up
this is the incredible power of extreme
wealth the alleged crimes and legal
disasters from some of the most
prominent families in america because
billionaires don't play by the same
rules as the rest of us
this is dark capital
claire bronfman was born into one of the
most prominent families in modern
history
she had the means to live any way she
wanted anywhere she wanted
but of all the paths she could have
taken she took the path that led to her
serving time in federal prison for her
leadership role in nexium
[Music]
this is how claire and her sister sarah
poured more than 100 million dollars
into one of the most notorious cults of
the 21st century
edgar bronfman senior was the son of
samuel bronfman a russian immigrant who
built sigrums into one of the largest
distillers in the world and got rich
during prohibition
claire and sarah were the two youngest
children of the late billionaire edgar
bronfman senior
edgar senior and their mother rita
georgiana webb divorced for the second
time in the 1990s and the girls spent
most of their time living with their
mother in the english countryside
claire was introverted and never
finished high school instead training as
a competitive show jumper
her sister sara describes her as being
sweet caring a little clumsy and
incredibly sensitive
claire and her sister sarah grew up on a
farm with their mother but when they
turned 18 a trust fund was waiting for
each
sarah says we were not raised to be
heiresses nor did we understand we would
be we grew up in another world we were
just like everyone else but then we
weren't
unbeknownst to us we had millions of
dollars awaiting us on our 18th
birthdays
in the beginning nexium was offering
executive coaching classes and appeared
to be like other innocuous self-help
groups
edgar senior took a course and thought
it could benefit both claire and sarah
who were struggling to find a purpose in
their life
they too enrolled to the delight of
keith renery
but edgar's enthusiasm waned and became
suspicious of ranieri's intentions after
realizing that claire loaned her leader
two million dollars
it kind of opened up his eyes through
this loan he realized like oh my god
my daughters might be targeted
because of their immense wealth
in 2003 we put keith renery who's the
leader of nexium on the cover of forbes
and the blockbuster quote from that
piece is edgar bronfman saying i think
it's a cult
what this article looked into is the
more strange and concerning behaviors of
keith and certain members of the group
the curtain was drawn back it was like
this guy is
not the smartest man in the world
this group has manipulative tendencies
and even its course work is really
concerning
so this article really put nexium's
darker
tendencies on the map and um it really
put nexium's story in the mainstream
media
the fallout for the story was really
unclear
and it indebted her to keith for their
whole relationship it was this turning
point where he finally had something
over her
she like owed it to him to try to fix it
but you know obviously it could never be
fixed because the damage was done
keith made claire believe that her
father had it out for him and that he
wanted to destroy nexium and that edgar
was part of the illuminati you know like
really crazy paranoid
things
while edgar senior publicly and
privately voiced his suspicions claire
found a purpose and community within
nexium and refused to part ways with the
group
after the forbes article was published
claire had spyware installed onto her
father's computer to monitor him
according to witness testimony
according to claire's lawyer her and her
father made up and she helped take care
of him at the end of his life
i think it's easy for us to
look at these people who um you know are
in news stories being in a cult like how
could that ever happen like they must be
stupid and their eyes must be closed you
know cults don't advertise like hey join
us it's [ __ ] nuts over here like we
do insane things and it's dangerous and
scary
it's just a group of like-minded people
who want to get along and chat after
time goes on you realize they cut you
off from the world or you know tell you
you know it's not the best to tell your
friends what we do here and then
eventually that alienation starts and um
the closest people to you in your life
are are people in this group and then
it's too late or it's really hard to to
separate because you know you do grow
fondness for people that you spend time
with so i think that to me that was the
most interesting aspect that it's
not hard
rick ross a cult deprogrammer and
founder of the cult education institute
defended himself against a 14-year long
lawsuit waged by keith rainery and
offers his perspective on the group
nexium targeted celebrities targeted the
wealthy and these people were conned
keith renery would have imploded a long
time before
he did if it wasn't for the fact that
claire bronfman was his bank
she and her sister sarah were feeding
him millions and millions and millions
of dollars including paying for all of
his
litigation
there was this incredible sucking sound
coming out of their bank because the
money was being vacuumed into keith
renery's coffers to pay for all of his
lawyers
another thing he did that was really
interesting psychologically speaking um
was seagram's is a canadian company and
when the u.s prohibited alcohol
seagram's put whiskey distilleries on
the border of u.s and canada and their
whiskey was fed right into the black
market
how keith spun their fortune was like
your fortune is dirty your fortune is
evil it came from crime like all this
all this crazy stuff he said like claire
you need to clean this money and you can
clean it through nexium because we're a
noble ethical organization
and
claire bought into that
claire gave more than 100 million
dollars to nexium over 15 years
a major chunk of her money went towards
suing nexium's enemies both real and
perceived to smithereens
sarah eventually left the group got
married and moved away she was never
charged with any crimes
but claire remained a devoted member
over 15 years it's estimated that claire
hired 50 to 60 lawyers to pursue cases
against nearly a dozen nexium critics
at least three people who defended
themselves against nexium's aggressive
legal strategy eventually filed for
personal bankruptcy protection
[Music]
barbara boucher joined nexium in 2001
and was one of its earliest executive
board members she dated keith for many
years
she also owned a successful financial
planning company becoming claire and
sarah's financial advisor and managed a
small portion of their wealth
bouche was the first person to sound the
alarm on the unethical practices within
the group and eventually left the group
after her departure keith went after her
in both civil and criminal court over
the duration of the next eight years
14 litigations four states eight judges
there were thousands of court filings
and barbara spent almost a million
dollars defending herself
ultimately all charges against barbara
were dropped
it's been 20 years of my life and it's
taken a toll on my body and my nervous
system and i still have a lot of
post-traumatic stress
keith used claire's money
as a reign of terror
within the organization
if it were not for claire brothman
he would have never been able to have
done any of that and probably would have
been brought down a hell of a lot sooner
than he was
so claire's very responsible she played
a key role
the tipping point was the day the new
york times published their article about
dos a secretive group within nexium
federal investigators then arrested
keith renery on charges of racketeering
sex trafficking conspiracy forced labor
identity theft sexual exploitation of a
child and possession of child
pornography
a few months later claire bronfman was
indicted and charged with a racketeering
conspiracy including identity theft
extortion forced labor sex trafficking
money laundering wire fraud and
obstruction of justice
bronfman made a deal with prosecutors
and only pled guilty to identity theft
and immigration fraud and was sentenced
to 81 months in prison
reneri was convicted on all charges and
will spend the rest of his life in
prison
probably one of the saddest things that
came about through the trial was this
email exchange between claire and her
father
edgar writes whether or not you want to
believe me i do not lie and i love you
too very much
someone is not telling you the truth
why don't you try and figure out who
that might be
who has something to gain certainly not
me
what would be my motive
and then he signs off tons of love even
if not requited pops
keith saw a rift in a family dynamic and
he exploited it for his own personal
gain
she justified it for the greater good
and that is the crime
because keith can influence her all he
wants people can say she was brainwashed
and unduly influenced and i beg to
differ
it's claire who chooses to pick up that
sword
and that's why she's a criminal she knew
it was wrong and she did it anyway
i really do think that there is goodness
in her i've seen it i know it and i
believe that she in the end wants to do
right and wants to be a humanitarian
she is a woman with wealth powers and
means
to
fix the wrongs which most people would
never have
that kind of
ability to do so she could turn this
around and become
you know quite the story down the road
[Music]
do
the night of august 3rd 1976 started off
peacefully
priscilla davis and stan farr were
coming back from a night out with their
friends and pulling up to her fort worth
mansion
but as soon as priscilla stepped into
her kitchen she came face to face with a
man dressed entirely in black and
wearing a woman's wig the man only said
hi
before shooting her in the chest
[Music]
the shooter would ultimately leave two
dead and one paralyzed that night yet
somehow priscilla survived
and when it came time to identify the
shooter priscilla had no doubt in her
mind her estranged husband colin davis
wasn't just the prime suspect but an
heir to one of america's wealthiest
families
and he was being charged with capital
murder
at the time he was reported to be
america's richest murder defendant ever
[Music]
[Laughter]
davis hi mr davis it's noah kersh from
forbes calling you back
as you may have guessed i'm writing a
story here just kind of retelling the
story of priscilla
uh
whose idea to
drag this up
[Music]
cullen's father's name was kenneth davis
but he went by stinky and he ran this
firm called ken davis industries which
was worth tens of millions of dollars if
not more
ken davis ended up passing the firm down
to three of his sons one of whom was
cullen
priscilla wilborn came from a really
different background she came from a
blue-collar town in texas and she never
knew her father
cullen's affair with priscilla started
at their country club
but quickly progressed into something
serious
each got divorced from their current
partners
it was cullen's first divorce and
priscilla's second
cullen and priscilla tied the knot on
august 29 1968 the very day that
cullen's father died
cullen immediately began building their
19 000 square foot dream home that he
would share with priscilla for a number
of years until priscilla decided to end
the marriage in 1974.
that july on her 33rd birthday she filed
for divorce
and a day after that cullen found
himself forced off of his own property
he was court-ordered not to come on or
around the mansion or its 181 acre
grounds until their divorce was
finalized
it was a messy time
two years passed since the filing and
there was still no resolution
by this time priscilla had a new
boyfriend stan farr who lived with her
in the very mansion from which cullen
was banned
[Music]
naturally as soon as she was shot
priscilla screamed really loudly which
alerted her lover as she called him this
guy stan farr who was like six foot five
and he sprinted towards the kitchen at
which point he encountered the shooter
who shot and killed him
by coincidence just as the shooting
happened two of priscilla's friends
pulled into the driveway and the shooter
went outside and shot one of them in the
spine and paralyzed him
police arrived at the chaotic scene of
the crime
first responders rushed priscilla and
bubba gavrill who was also shot to the
hospital
priscilla despite bleeding from her
gunshot wound was able to identify the
shooter she said it was her estranged
husband cullen davis
when she arrived at the hospital she
found out her 12 year old daughter
andrea wilborn had also been killed
police issued an all-points bulletin for
cullen and he was arrested at his new
girlfriend's home
authorities found five weapons in the
trunk of his car
but none of them matched the murder
weapon
cullen was first charged over andrea's
murder and though the evidence in that
case was largely circumstantial he faced
a possible death sentence
he hired one of the top trial lawyers in
the country richard racehorse haynes to
defend him in court in the murder of
twelve-year-old andrea
haynes attacked priscilla's reputation
and undermined her credibility
the trial went on for three months and
cullen was found not guilty
decades after the trial it came to light
that a member of cohen's defense team
was paying someone in the district
attorney's office five thousand dollars
every single month to give intel on the
prosecution strategy it was a huge
amount of money back then and it's
completely possible that it altered the
course of that trial
nine months later one of cullen's
friends approached the fbi saying that
cullen had wanted him to hire a hitman
to kill 15 people including priscilla
and the judge was presiding over their
divorce
federal agents set up a sting operation
to get him to admit to soliciting a
hitman
again he hired racehorse haines and
again he was found not guilty
cullen got married once again and
priscilla moved to dallas where she
spent five years living with greg brown
yeah how do you say greg brown in one or
two words
greg brown is one of priscilla's closest
friends from later in life and actually
wrote a book about their relationship
does that work
i mean they were lovers too technically
it's pretty complicated
listen i moved in with priscilla i was
25 she was 54.
she had been the most glamorous woman
living the largest mansion with the
richest man
we were both
heavy drinkers
i was gay but it was
a fun
fun life being her lover
priscilla kept calling in court you know
this case just didn't go away when
cullen was acquitted of the murder of
andrea and of the hit job on the judge
[Music]
if you don't mind i'd like to ask you
about some of the controversial things
during that tumultuous period
i know there was an interview
where you talked about dee's cat
can you tell me about that incident
that was
priscilla's
daughter d
that
this event something i told her to do
and
when i confronted her about it
she got
smart alecky
and
she was holding this kitten
brand new kitten
and
i just grabbed it and threw it down
it died
that's basically what happened
you sound like someone maybe who used to
get angry but over time has mellowed is
that fair
i didn't get
that angry very often
throwing things or hitting people but
you could say that would be an accurate
statement
did you ever hit priscilla
she lied to me about something
and i didn't punch her i slapped her on
my face
that was the only time
so i i mean i assume your position still
is that you had nothing to do with the
shooting at the house
that's correct
who do you think could have done it
no possible idea
i think that her school has been
forgotten
priscilla was the most vivacious
magnet
that people were drawn to because
of both her glamour and her positive
energy
she's been vilified of course and she's
thought of as the beautiful blonde
bombshell that was on the other side of
the tracks and as we know that's how
colin got off for the murder of her
child
[Music]
so
doris duke was tall
blonde
beautiful and rich a tabloid staple
the mid 20th century wasn't the viral
celebrity sex tape world we live in now
but the press was still incredibly
invasive
so when news broke that doris this
famous socialite from one of america's
richest families might have
intentionally killed her best friend the
public geared up for the trial of the
century
justice would be swift for doris they
thought
but they would be wrong
[Music]
i first started looking into the doris
dude car crash last year a little over
five decades since the incident occurred
i grew up in new jersey not far from one
of doris duke's estates so i was pretty
familiar with her doris duke is known
for her philanthropy she's given a lot
of money away to charity she's all these
foundations in her name but there's all
this mystery around her she was so much
of a recluse and she really liked to
privacy so people are always drawn to
her and to know more because
she was so tucked away from society in a
way she was a reluctant public figure
who did not like to be in the limelight
but again she was drawn into the
limelight because at the time she was
one of the richest women in the world
newport was a summer playground for the
wealthy
duke loved the peace and privacy and it
wasn't surprising that she enjoyed
octobers there when the summer homes
were left vacant as tourists returned to
the city
she lived somewhat anonymously tucked
away in her property as she liked
she spent years there before the
accident which wouldn't happen until she
turned 53
she was settled down as much as a person
of her celebrity could be
doris duke and edward tyrella knew each
other for a good decade they're pretty
close companions
they confide in each other
eduardo tarella was a new jersey native
he was famous in his own right he was an
interior designer as well as a movie set
designer ed water was also her artistic
curator and he helped design her homes
on her many estates so she trusted him
and really sought his advice when
designing her homes
[Music]
according to an article in vanity fair
eduardo was planning to give his notice
that he was going to cut personal and
professional ties with doris and head
out west to california
he wanted to get his career in the film
industry off the ground and felt that
duke was stifling it
if he was going to stay with her he was
never going to make it big
eduardo told his partner as well as
friends and family that he was going to
cut ties with doris duke and they warned
him about this
they said it would anger her and that it
wouldn't end well
but he wanted to tell her in person and
that's why he was with her the day the
accident happened
that night doris wanted eduardo to drive
her to an appointment
they got in the car ready to go eduardo
was in the driver's seat but he had to
get out to go open the gate to get onto
bellevue avenue so he put the car in
park and he got out and door slid over
into the driver's seat she claims that
this car suddenly let forward she
doesn't know what happened and at some
point eduardo was pinned against the
gate and the car crashed straight
through the gate and into a tree on
bellevue avenue
doris was found in a fog wandering
around she was bleeding from head wounds
and she didn't know what happened and
had water was found under the back of
the car crushed he had died instantly
police did not question duke for two
days after the accident occurred
why did officials wait 48 hours to
question the only witness of eduardo
torrella's last moments
reporters were stationed around her
gates trying to get access to anyone who
worked for her but it was under
investigation and the police weren't
talking
not even a little over a week after this
incident occurred she was donating money
left and right she gave 25 000
to restore a historic cliff walk in
newport then soon after she gave
10 grand to newport hospital which is
where she had been staying after the
incident and a few months later
following these donations she had set up
the newport restoration fund which was
meant to restore 84 colonial arab
buildings in newport
a lot of people believe she bought her
way out of this that she paid blood
money to make this go under the rug and
just forget about it to get her out of
the limelight and that pretend this
never happened
a lot of the evidence seems like it was
mislabeled or it just mysteriously
vanished even court cases her statements
so it seems like whether there was a
cover-up or the police didn't do their
job there was a lack of accountability
at the time and that's what makes it so
much harder to dive into this case and
find out what truly happened
the official conclusion of the
investigation was that terrella's death
was not intentional rather it was just
an unfortunate accident
but the terrellas maintained that doris
duke intentionally and deliberately ran
over eduardo
they filed a suit against her in 1967
seeking 1.25 million dollars
for years the case dragged on and five
years after the incident doris duke was
found guilty of negligence and ordered
to pay the family seventy-five thousand
dollars
the fact that ed water was such her
close friend why wouldn't she want to
help them out and
be there for them at this time she
caused the death of her friend
the story of the car crash incident
pretty much was a blood stain on doris
duke's legacy while she did a lot of
great philanthropy and she donated a lot
of money and she really did help people
this just couldn't go away this was on
her record forever people couldn't stop
talking about it and while she was a
recluse early on and into her later
years especially you know people were
still curious what really did happen
well the only person who actually knows
what happened is doris duke and she took
that secret right to her grave
[Music]
robert h richards iv raped and sexually
abused his four-year-old daughter for
the last time
as he had before he warned her to keep
this a secret but this time she didn't
she told her grandmother who told her
mother who told their pediatrician who
told the police
richards was arrested and charged with
two counts of second-degree rape
punishable by a minimum prison term of
20 years
but richards an heir to the 16 billion
dupont family fortune didn't get
anywhere near the minimum of 20 years in
jail
in fact he got none at all he pled
guilty to a charge of rape in the fourth
degree paid a fine of 4 395
and promised to attend a high-end
treatment center in massachusetts which
he technically couldn't because he
wasn't allowed to leave the state of
delaware
so that's where he stayed receiving
psychiatric care and group counseling
for sex offenders
and this all stayed under the radar for
six whole years
[Music]
family history goes back to the french
revolution the duponts were actually
very close with louis xvi who was
executed during the french revolution so
after he was executed the dupont family
decided to flee france and they came to
the united states
the dupont company which originally
manufactured gunpowder transitioned into
a chemical giant and today has revenues
of 21.5 billion dollars
the family is huge
around 4 000 members share the 16
billion family fortune
they've had notable members like pete
dupont the former governor of delaware
but they've also had their share of
criminals like john dupont who was found
guilty of the murder of olympic gold
medalist david schultz and he later died
in jail
and while it took a few years the
unemployed tier 2 sex offender robert
richards living off the family trust
fund was now in the public eye
a rich man walks free after he admits he
rapes his three-year-old little girl
are you aware the dupont family owns
delaware pretty much
the public outrage started in 2014 when
the mother of robert richard's children
filed a civil lawsuit asking for
monetary damages for robert's crime this
was the first time the general public
heard about the 2008 case
we don't know why
local media
missed the news it's
not easy the civil
suit revealed that during his
psychiatric treatment
robert
was actually
not really revealing all of his thoughts
and in 2010 his sex offender counselor
asked for a polygraph in which it was
revealed that robert may have also
touched his younger son
but for whatever the reason
the further allegations were
investigated but they never led to
another charge
so the words that the judge said at the
time was you know you have incredible
family support and you should be
grateful for that and you should get
treated so
a lot of people said
is this the type of treatment that
someone else would have gotten so i
dug into this i reached out to the
police department that was investigating
this i also reached out to robert
richards himself and no one would
comment on this eugene moore did not
want to talk to me i also reached out to
judge jan jordan who presided over the
case at the time for comment and she
wouldn't comment any further on the case
and it is you know almost impossible
when no one talks to you it's almost
impossible to find out if he actually
did get special treatment but even
though we don't know that what we know
is that he had access to the best lawyer
in delaware
and
only the richest people
can do that
so he had that
in his favor the fact that he could tap
into any source
that he could
eugene j moore jr is known as one of the
most prolific defense attorneys in
delaware
famously defending stephen b pennell the
delaware serial killer as well as former
delaware deputy attorney general thomas
capano who is found guilty of murdering
his girlfriend
during richard's sentencing moore called
the six foot four nearly 300-pound
richards a somewhat gentle person and
argued he would not fare well in jail
hours later richards walked away from
delaware superior court a free man
but now that this was all made public
people wanted answers
judge jan jordan took much of the heat
getting so many threats she ended up
hiring private security detail
in addition beau biden acting attorney
general at the time also received much
scrutiny
so much so he published an op-ed in
delaware's the news journal defending
the
punishment meaning if this case went to
trial and roberts was found not guilty
he would have walked away free without
any restrictions but by not bringing the
case to trial the court was able to
nearly guarantee he would be registered
as a sex offender receive counseling and
be on probation and parole
one thing that i found out when i was
talking to an expert who looks at crimes
against children
that it is
very hard to convict someone
when the victim is a minor and is very
very young because children at very
young ages are not really considered
strong witnesses so in the case of
the rape of a minor
it is easier for someone to make a case
that they are not guilty
in robert's case
he had already pleaded guilty but again
the current system
kind of enabled him
to
get away
with a smaller punishment in comparison
to jail time
[Music]
you